you know we all have we all have that
flaky friend do you have that frankie
friend who claims they're going to come
to the party and then they just never
come to the party
wait raise of hands who does have that
flaky friend oh
god raise of hands are you at times that
flaky friend
yeah i'm only the people i'm not that
close with and i try and then i don't
make it so we've all been there no
judgments but i do know those people who
like every time you send an invite
you're like they're never showing
they're no they're a save but they but
they're not going to show up well now a
style stylist reports there's another
type of friend to watch out for the
can't stay for long friend do you know
them
can't say for long friend is that friend
who's who does show up but they sit down
to dinner and immediately start talking
about where they have to go next
and they say they can only stay for like
a drink or an hour and then they just
have to go
um some say it's rough being friends
with these people because after a while
it feels like there's like they're
rejecting you
i think i'm this friend
because i do i do find myself saying
whenever people say like oh do you want
to go to dinner i'm like it's got to be
like 5 45 or 6 or i'm like out you know
that i think that's exempt from this
category because i'm like that too early
bird special i now have two kids a
full-time job and i'm really tired and i
got to get to bed early but i have met
people who tell me that they've got to
go when they get there and i agree with
this article it does feel like a mini
rejection does it really because this is
how i see it okay i've got a train to
take home i got to work in the morning
so no i can't sit with you at dinner
till 10 but i can pop by for a drink and
then bye-bye
i think there's actually i'm not
rejecting you i'm trying to do what i
can to meet you in the middle all right
show of hands how many people think it
makes you feel a little cagey and weird
when someone says they gotta go right
when they start the event
show of hands who thinks this is a
prudent way to live you can get more
done
i'm good with it well it looks like
there's something for everybody yeah we
found our happy little middle as you
call a pretty little that's it yeah my
favorite i want to live there
um all right finally uh some good news
if you love a good cruise oh my gosh you
know how much i love going on a cruise i
do too and like i want the cruise
industry to be thriving and they've been
hit so hard with the pandemic but i was
so excited to bring this story to the
news desk because it turns out that cnn
reports the cdc has fully lifted its
cove advisory on cruises that's right
baby
the cruise industry is back baby yay
i love it do you want to know one thing
i really love about cruises besides the
fact that it's literally a floating
buffet which is everything he wants
well it's great for families it's great
for singles there's theme cruises
so like if you're a turner classics
movie or you want to do the love boat
theme or you want to like do a booze
cruise to mexico like they've got it all
you can go to scandinavia
i think a lot of people get intimidated
with planning
where do i go how do i stay how do i
build the itinerary can i afford this
it's
jarring to travel
and i feel like they just button
everything up you get on you get off you
see you look we've got your back we take
care of all that and every morning you
wake up and open the windows like where
am i now it's so fun this is so awesome
well to celebrate we've got something
really special nothing says fancy crews
like finding a towel in the swan shape
right in your room and today we're gonna
make them because a tick tocker named
the folding lady who totally is going
viral right now just revealed how to do
it step by step
okay okay let's try it some people are
intimidated by travel i'm intimidated by
trying to make a towel swan i i didn't
even know this was a thing until i went
on a cruise and i walked in the room and
i was like what is that
there's a towel so one on my bed okay so
i was watching her okay do you think you
know how to do it because i'm scared
right now i'm like 100 sure i don't know
how to make it i just watched her do it
and see she pinches the corner and then
it's a look it's like a tight roll like
wait from the corner corner oh okay see
what i'm doing just you got to hold the
middle i think and then just roll tight
okay so like when you get to the
midpoint start rolling the other side i
think so
and then look
[Applause]
my swan looks like it is so drunk just
look look
wait okay now now you lift it up and
it's supposed to be tight enough that it
sort of stays but i don't think it is
but you kind of get the idea right nope
you've heard of um you've heard of swan
lake well this is swan like
what does mine look like
um can i see a shot of it
oh
you know
actually it's not terrible it looks more
like a snake yeah
um
that's like going to hiss at you
but
i have surprised myself i
what's what's yours look like well mine
looks pretty good and i think
with like i'm not i'm not trying to be
rude rossi but i think mine looks more
like a swan than yours
dear it's time to get your eyes checked
all right
but my my mine looks like a duck
oh my god i'm holding
the wrong one i'm looking at yours
you were looking at mine thinking it was
yours
no this is me
that's you oh my god i was like mine's
so much better than yours rossi oh my
god i'm having the moment like in a
workout class when you're in the mirror
and you're like damn i look good and
you're like that's not me that's uh
shoot okay mine sucks yours is amazing
i i understand now i did have my eyes
checked rossi and yours is better i'm
good for you
oh my gosh yours wasn't all it was
quacked up to be
[Music]